good morning John I very much enjoy
making things and I think that most
people enjoy making thing making songs
making scarves making video blogs making
books making it rain like Roger like
take things that are inside of their
head and make them real in the real
world and and this is hard but I've been
doing it for a while now and I'm getting
better at it
I think that's because of a combination
of attitudes and resources that I now
have for other people who want to make
things and I may be having a hard time
doing I wanted to share my process in
the form of a case study read it first
dot-com which I had launched last night
candy I do every year ago and the
process of having an idea is very that
just has to happen I like the idea that
because it had a lot of the things that
I need for good ideas one it promotes
something that I love read to through
advertising it could potentially
actually employ a writer and I would
love to be responsible for a writer
having a job sorry it seemed kind of
nerd fight astok it seemed kind of like
something that nerdfighters would enjoy
but first before nerdfighteria I had to
explain the idea to Kathryn Cather is my
wife and she's also my number one wall
at which to throw ideas and if they
stick to her then this is very good size
she's smart enough and loving enough to
be both quick and entirely merciless now
we have approached the most interest
part of the process for me I took my
initial feedback and I put it in my head
with the idea and sat there doing the
process you have lots of good ideas
about the idea and how to make the idea
perfect what's not happening as the idea
is not actually becoming real it's just
becoming cooler inside of your brain we
call this brain crack and zefrank
has freed me from my addiction to fly
brain crack this idea for like a year
and then I'm with the LeakyCon where I
got rien spired about books and
adaptations and how people should read
the book first I needed a domain name
went to Busta name com grudgingly
settled on a domain name that has a
number in it and this may not have been
the best decision in the world but I
want to emphasize that it was a decision
making an unperfect decision is far are
better than not making a decision which
is the worst possible decision you can
make then I went into my design software
fireworks and I made up a logo and I
tweeted it and I put it on my tongue and
lots of people gave me great feedback
and tons of amazing genius ideas about
how to make read it first bet and I
ignored all of reader first needs one
thing to do its job it needs a
newsletter and so that's all we did to
start we also went through about a dozen
logo incarnations on tumblr which was a
really rewarding critique for me and
then I executive decision settled on a
logo which we are now stuck with not
because it was the best logo possible
but because we need
then I designed a website around the
logo all by myself I do this because I'm
a passable designer and then because I'm
no longer a passable HTML coder I sent
it off to a company called PSD to HTML
and my design into an actual web page
then I suckered a friend of mine Sam Raj
into making the code that makes the
whole site work and then I suckered my
brother John Green into writing the
first few editions of the read it first
newsletter first one will be going out
Friday morning never worry about asking
people to do favors for you especially
when they're not like huge gigantic
hunks of time but if money starts to
exist with a project always remember
those people who helped you and reward
them for that with money do I need to
say that you reward them with money I do
not know if this is a good idea that's
the thing about ideas you will never
know if it's a good idea until you make
it real and when the world doesn't like
the idea that is called failure and it
sounds and it feels so much worse than
it is
I now have a lot of failures under my
belt and I don't mind so much anymore
what is an amazing way to feel if you
want to create things I mean obviously
success is much more enjoyable if you
suffer to the failure that you never do
it your chances of success are none and
of course I went all over FET here to go
and sign up for read it first but I also
want you to know that this isn't
something that I created for
nerdfighters I created it for the world
what I did was I created it with
nerdfighters and I really believed that
I really believed that I couldn't have
done any of this I didn't have a
resource that no one else in the world
has except for John Green a group of
intelligent interesting interested savvy
Tom blogging made of awesome people
thanks not just for this but for
everything that we've created together
everyone can go and sign up at read it
first calm now and don't forget to tell
your friends on I'll see you on Friday